peu
[Musique]
le destin tragique de lady diana le
conte de fées a tourné au drame cette
nuit à paris à 36 ans lady diana a
trouvé la mort dans un accident de
voiture en compagnie de son nouvel ami
le milliardaire égyptien
dodi al fayed leur voiture poursuivie
par des paparazzi à moto roulait à très
grande vitesse lorsque le conducteur en
a perdu le contrôle récit pascal golomer
patrick voit une carcasse littéralement
broyé l'état de la voiture témoigne de
la violence extrême du choc la puissante
mercedes était lancé à pleine vitesse
dans le tunnel de l'alma en plein paris
vers zéro heure trente sans doute plus
de 150 km pour une raison encore
inconnue
elle est venue heurter le mur puis l'un
des piliers du tunnel à son bord quatre
personnes
lady diana son ami dodi al fayed un
garde du corps et le chauffeur il venait
de quitter l'hôtel rixos place vendôme
pour fausser compagnie aux paparazzi qui
les suivaient à moto le chauffeur aurait
alors décidé de rouler très vite trop
vite
lorsque la police et les secours
arrivent sur place
deux d al fayed et le chauffeur sont
déjà décédés la princesse de galles
elle peut être désincarcéré l'opération
prend plus d'une heure avant le
transfert vers l'hôpital de la pitié
salpêtrière
pendant ce temps l'enquète débute cette
photographe sont rapidement emmené dans
les locaux de la brigade criminelle
les motos sont saisis comme pièces à
conviction peu avant 6 heures à
l'hôpital de la pitié salpêtrière
les journalistes sont conviés à une
conférence de presse improvisée
thoracotomie d'urgence a mis en évidence
une plaie importante de la veine
pulmonaire gauche malgré la fermeture de
cette plaie et un massage cardiaque
externe puis interne de deux heures
aucune efficacité circulatoire n'a pu
être rétablie et le décès dé constater à
4 heures du matin j'adresse les
condoléances de la france à la famille
royale aux familles des victimes
et au peuple britannique tout entier
lady diana
c'était une personne très aimé en france
une femme moderne courageuse sensible à
la détresse humaine sa disparition sera
ressentie douloureusement dans notre
pays
quai des orfèvres les sept photographes
sont alors toujours interrogé par les
enquêteurs de la brigade criminelle
le jour se lève les premiers parisien se
présente sous le tunnel de l'alma ou
rendre un dernier hommage à lady diana
princesse de galles
très grièvement blessée la princesse
diana donc été transporté au service de
réanimation de l'hôpital de la pitié
salpêtrière où le décès a été constaté à
4 heures du matin l'ambiance sur place
avec ce reportage de valérie fournier
michel levasseur le premier ministre
lionel jospin et bernadette chirac sont
arrivés à 9 heures dans deux voitures
séparées précédé de peu par
l'ambassadeur de grande bretagne en
france depuis très tôt ce matin une
foule d'anonymes s'est pressée devant
l'hôpital de la pitié salpêtrière où les
boues diana est décédée cette nuit à 4
heures du matin pour moi elle était
adorable
je viendrai
ce tu sois là dans ma mère
pour ces enfants
[Musique]
oui
tu es triste
[Musique]
ça a fait beaucoup de bien lui a
toujours fait du mal et les gens qui lui
ont fait du mal c'est vraiment répugnant
à voile à helsa vraiment ça nous touche
vraiment à coeur une colère à mots
couverts contre la presse en particulier
ceux qui violent la vie privée des stars
pour de fortes sommes
une colère que certains n'arrivait pas à
contenir même bouleversé au delà de tout
ce qu'elle a pu faire c'est fallait pas
la traque et dans sa vie privée au seul
regard des qu' on est toujours à la
poursuite d'un espèce de d'argent piquer
de l'argent souvent c'est le capitalisme
à la sauvage et la mort n'est ce pas de
cette femme
si généreux
quand même pu table n'est ce pas aux
médias tout ce que je voyais des
journaux de ce que je voyais ce gel ou
toute une collection même les dernières
qui vient de sortir tout parce que même
la presse à scandales même vous en
voulez aux photographes qui les suit 20
janvier j'en vois énormément à la presse
qu'il est souvent une presse encore très
présents ce matin devant l'hôpital de la
pitié salpêtrière où les badauds
continuent d'affluer dans le silence et
le recueillement
montrons tout de suite en direct de
l'hôpital de la pitié salpêtrière benoît
duquesne benoît le prince charles est
attendu dans l'après midi
oui tout à fait le prince charles était
confirmée un peu plus tard dans la
matinée depuis londres le prince charles
doit se rendre ici
cet après midi on sait que les
cérémonies ici seront brèves puisque
après qu'il se soit recueilli sur la
dépouille de son ex-femme et bien le
corps de lady diana doit être rapatrié
sur londres où là les cérémonies
officielles angleterre auront lieu tout
cela doit se faire relativement
rapidement dans l'après midi on ne sait
pas encore si d'autres personnalités que
celles qui sont déjà venus ce matin
doivent se rendre encore ici cet après
midi mais il y à issy comme vous le
voyez pas mal de badauds de gens qui
sont là pour les uns pour témoigner de
leur affection pour la princesse et pour
d'autres pour voir un petit peu comment
les choses évoluent merci jacques chirac
a fait part de sa vive émotion évoquant
la mémoire de lady diana
une jeune femme de notre temps
chaleureuse pleine de vie et de
générosité la plupart des grands de ce
monde ont fait part de leur tristesse et
de leur consternation
de nombreux curieux se sont rendus ce
matin sur les lieux de l'accident dans
le tunnel du pont de l'alma où nous
retrouvons sur place en direct marie
pierre farkas
oui nous assistons depuis ce matin des
scènes de recueillement des scènes
recueillement populaire anonyme
vous voyez juste derrière moi sur le
pont il ya un bouquet de roses il n'y en
aura qu'un parce que maintenant des
policiers interdisent à la fois l'accès
du tunnel et les alentours
depuis ce matin vous allez voir sur ces
images tournées par jacques gregor
depuis ce matin 9 heures ce sont des
français
bado des passants des touristes
étrangers qui sont venus des
britanniques
chacun portait une fleur sous ce
treizième poteau du tunnel du pont de
l'alma
écoutez lente et moyen âge ou sa liste
américaine dit qu'elle est très triste
parce que diana était une princesse
gentil qu'elle aimait beaucoup et
beaucoup de gens sont tristes objets que
j'ai appris la nouvelle ce matin
allant chercher mon pain j'ai tout de
suite eu une pensée pour les deux
princes bien évidemment bon
je ne vais pas tarder à aller à la messe
et je vais les porter dans ma prière je
crois que ça la seule chose
personnellement que je puisse faire
il ya eu des fleurs ce matin beaucoup de
fleurs des larmes des femmes assez
triste et puis surtout un début de
polémique parce que beaucoup des gens
qui étaient là ne voulait pas témoigner
parce qu'ils étaient émus mais dont on
ne voulait pas s'adresser à la presse
quand ce touriste anglais qui refuse de
parler à la presse qui la rend
responsable or dans le courant de la
matinée nous avons rencontré d'autres
témoins qui le disaient que finalement
il avait vu une voiture mais vous
connaissez la fragilité de ces
témoignages dans ces instants-là vu une
voiture qui n'était pas accompagnée de
motards en tout cas il se passe ici le
plus beau témoignage que nous ayons
recueillez est celui d'une femme
israélienne qui disait qu'il n'y a pas
de façon intelligente de mourir mais que
celle ci était particulièrement stupide
nancy marie pierre farkas pour toutes
ces précisions pour le premier ministre
britannique lady d'aiete la princesse du
peuple à 20 en juillet 80 elle avait
épousé charles l'héritier du trône
britannique
en compagnie de patrice romedenne récit
d'un conte de fées qui a tourné à la
tragédie
la majesté de l'endroit est à la mesure
de l'événement
le 29 juillet 1981 à la cathédrale saint
paul de londres le prince charles
épouser une jeune fille issue de la fine
fleur de l'aristocratie britten en
liesse les sujets de sa majesté fait
l'élu adopté dès l'annoncé des
fiançailles les pommettes rosies par
l'amour et la gaucherie la désormais
princesse 19 ans s'affiche au bras de
charles 32 ans
ils s'aiment et ils le disent vous vous
aimez bien sûr de l' union naîtront deux
enfants et l'ennui ce préambule à
l'explosion du couple harry et william
aujourd'hui 13 et 15 ans seule la
progéniture rapproche les parents il
aime la solitude le polo la philosophie
hindoue et l architecture
il apprécie berlioz elle se déhanche sur
d'ailleurs ce trade secours les
discothèques et les balles chacun vie
ses passions en solitaire et la lune de
miel la sombre dans le caniveau
il renoue avec camilla une amie
d'enfance elle s'amourache de james à
capitaine de cavalerie
pire aux yeux de buckingham c'est
qu'elle parle avec le capitaine êtes
vous allé au delà de l'amitié
je les fais avec vous a été infidèle et
ça ajoute m elle se dit je l'adorais
j'étais amoureuse de lui mais à quoi bon
cachet ou tenté de le faire des
couvertures par centaines d articles par
milliers pendant 17 ans la princesse
aura vécu avec dans son sillage un
bataillon de paparazzi soirées mondaines
officiel ou comme ici escapade privé
dans un club de gym
rien n'échappe à l'objectif des amateurs
de scoop dont l'assistance n'a d'égal
que la popularité de leur proie
le fil des révélations mais le couperet
du divorce cordone une reine ulcéré par
les déclarations de la princesse diana
perd son titre d'altesse mais conserve
celui de princesse de galles
elle empoche 23 millions de dollars et
munis de tels atouts entame une carrière
d'ambassadrice des grandes causes
symbolique la rencontre avec mère teresa
des enfants aux malades du sida en
passant par les victimes des mines
antipersonnel elle s'enquiert du sein
l'état de la planète
la seconde existence d'une femme dans la
force de l'âge dont la presse se fait
l'écho sans pour autant abandonner la
manne de la vie privée car en parallèle
la princesse conquiert un milliardaire
et playboy égyptien l'idylle nourrira le
roman-photo de l'été c'est à ses côtés
qu'elle est décédée cette nuit faisant
du coeur des britanniques son tombeau
dans un communiqué la reine elizabeth et
le prince charles se sont déclarés
anéantis par cette disparition tony
blair se dit totalement effondré pour le
premier ministre britannique
la grande bretagne est une nation et
pleurait du fait d'une mort profondément
douloureuse à londres pour france 2
etienne leenhardt
devant les grilles de buckingham palace
tôt ce matin le silence pour ce que tout
un peuple ressent comme une tragédie
diana princesse de galles est morte dans
la nuit et leur peine est immense
non nous sommes rentrer à la maison nous
avons entendu la nouvelle nous avons
suivi la télévision toute la nuit je
suis profondément choquée elle a su
donner du courage aux balades
elle était pleine de compassion la
presse l'a fait ils l'ont vraiment
fabriquer et maintenant ils l'ont tué
j'espère qu'ils en ont conscience
la même émotion devant les grilles de
kensington palace la résidence de diana
depuis son divorce des fleurs par
dizaines des messages et à l'heure des
prières là encore une immense émotion
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui nous sommes tous extrêmement choquée
et horrifiée
elle était merveilleuse ne savait faire
que le bien est celle de tout le monde
le choc et l'horreur absolue avant de se
rendre à l'office en compagnie de sa
femme et de ses enfants tony blair le
premier ministre visiblement ému à
évoquer sa mémoire chez était un être
merveilleux rempli de chaleur humaine sa
vie avaient été marquées par plusieurs
drames mais combien de gens at-elle su
aider ici en grande-bretagne est partout
à travers le monde depuis 4 heures ce
matin les programmes de toutes les
chaînes de télévision ont été
interrompues inlassablement les
chroniqueurs de la famille royale
évoquent sa mémoire sur le toit des
magasins harrods propriété du père de
dodi al fayed le drapeau britannique est
en baisse d'autres vont tout de suite en
direct du palais de buckingham etienne
leenhardt etienne le prince charles
était cette nuit au château de balmoral
en écosse et c'est apparemment lui et
lui même qui a annoncé à ses deux
enfants la mort de leur mère rapportent
les agences de presse officielles
britannique le prince charles qui a
appris la nouvelle pendant la nuit
comme tout le monde ici en
grande-bretagne et vous le disais au
début ce journal je crois qu'il ya
énormément d'émotion à la mesure de la
popularité qui était celle de la
princesse de galles
ici en grande bretagne même si elle
avait été critiqué en certaines
circonstances
nous sommes à buckingham palace où la
traditionnelle relève de la garde n'a
pas été annulé pour la pour la
circonstance il ya donc un mélange
curieux de d'émotion et en même temps de
tradition il y avait énormément de
touristes vous l'imaginez mais beaucoup
de gens ici qui sont venus également
pour assister traditionnellement à la
relève de la garde le prince charles se
rendra
on l'a dit tout à l'heure à paris en
compagnie des deux soeurs de la
princesse de galles pour se recueillir
sur la dépouille de son ex femme et pour
ramener la dépouille de la princesse de
galles en grande bretagne on ne sait pas
encore quelle apparence auront les
cérémonies officielles car vous savez
depuis un an depuis qu'elle a divorcé
la princesse de galles ne fait plus
officiellement partie de la famille
royale tout à l'heure à l'occasion de la
spéciale qui froisse journal et qui sera
présentée par daniel bilalian
cette romance avec le milliardaire
égyptien dodi al fayed le fils d'un des
hommes les plus controversées de grande
bretagne
c'est tison avait provoqué outre manche
un certain nombre de critiques pour ne
pas dire plus elle avait débuté comme un
roman feuilleton elle s'est donc achevée
dramatiquement cette nuit à paris sous
la traque des paparazzi en fait depuis
ses fiançailles avec charles à l'âge de
19 ans cette jeune femme avait vécu
constamment sous les objectifs des
caméras
etienne leenhardt à la une des éditions
spéciales de la matinée imprimé à la
hâte le dernier acte de ce qu'un
éditorialiste qualifie de tragédie
grecque
n'hésitant pas à mettre directement en
cause les paparazzis qu'elle sorte de
son club de gymnastique de chez elles ou
de nulle part il y avait toujours un
micro pour obtenir une confidence un
appareil pour figer un sourire une larme
ou un geste d'énervement la romance de
diana avec charge leur divorce leur
idylle respectives mobiliser plus la
presse britannique que tout autre
événement une publicité qu'elle jugeait
forcément excessive au cours d'une
journée normale je serai poursuivi par
quatre voitures de presse au cours d'une
journée normale jeu reviendra ma voiture
et je retrouverai sipa paradis pour le
piéger ils ont décidé qu'après 15 ou 16
ans je suis toujours un produit qui vend
du papier connue pour être la personne
la plus photographiée au monde en toutes
circonstances diana aura mis ces
dernières années sa médiatisation au
service des grandes causes
la médecine l'humanitaire et des
déplacements fréquents aux endroits les
plus misérables du monde où la présence
des photographes qu'elle entraîner
derrière elle était cette fois
nécessaire c'est très souvent par les
médias que la princesse communiquer avec
le public
elle avait une place dans le coeur du
public et je ne pense pas qu'on verra
quelqu'un d'autre prendre cette place
suivi pas à pas ces dernières semaines
jusque sur le yacht de son ami dodi al
fayed
dyan havre a dénoncé jusqu'au bout les
photographes qui la traquent et ceux là
mêmes qui depuis quinze ans ont aussi
contribué à bâtir son immense popularité
je vous propose maintenant d'entendre le
témoignage du frère de lady d'ailleurs
charles spencer
il évoque la responsabilité des
paparazzi dans ce drame
ce n'est pas le temps des accusations
mais celui de la tristesse je dirais
cependant que j'ai toujours pensé que la
presse finirait par la tuer mais je ne
pensais pas qu'ils auraient une
responsabilité aussi direct dans sa mort
il semble apparaître que tous les
patrons presse toutes les publications
qui ont payé pour encourager le travail
d'intrusion de photographes qui ne
cherchait que de l'argent dans la vie
privée de diana ont aujourd'hui du sang
sur leurs mains
le milliardaire égyptien
dodi al fayed a donc je vous le rappelle
trouvé la mort lui aussi dans cet
accident
son père c'est bien évidemment rendu dès
qu'il a eu connaissance du drame à paris
lle sortir
cachés par des gardes du corps de
l'hôtel du ritz à paris
les circonstances de cet accident vont
faire l'objet d'une enquête
particulièrement minutieuse enquête
confiée à la brigade criminelle une
procédure tout à fait exceptionnel
plusieurs photographes de presse sont
entendus depuis cette nuit au quai des
orfèvres
nous retrouvons tout de suite en direct
christophe tortora christophe ces
photographes serait en garde à vue oui
tout à fait il ya donc sept photographes
qui sont entendus ici à la brigade
criminelle ce qui est une procédure
exceptionnelle en raison de la
personnalité bien sûr des victimes les
sept hommes suivaient à moto la voiture
de lady di et du prince d'audi ils sont
donc entendus ici ils veulent témoigner
ils doivent témoigner des circonstances
exactes de l'accident sur ces sept
hommes six photographes sont de
nationalité française
le septième est de nationalité
macédonienne ils les motos de ses
photographes les appareils photos ont
été saisies par les inspecteurs de la
police judiciaire pour tenter de
comprendre les circonstances exactes de
cet accident
les coptes encore une question que
risque précisément sur le plan pénal ces
photographes
en fait tout dépend de la part de
responsabilité qui incombe à ces
photographes si le procureur estime
qu'ils sont totalement ou en partie
responsable de l'accident
il pourrait être mis en examen pour
homicide involontaire mais selon
certains témoins les photographes et les
motos se trouve à quelques centaines de
mètres derrière la voiture derrière la
mercedes de la princesse et du prince
dodine quoi qu'il en soit les
photographes certains photographes
pourrait être mise en examen pour
non-assistance à personne en danger
puisque certains d'entre eux on continue
à prendre des photos après l'accident
plutôt que de venir en aide aux
personnes qui étaient blessés ou tués
lors de cet accident et certains d'entre
eux pourraient être également poursuivi
pour délit de fuite puisqu'ils ont tenté
d'échapper au contrôle de police après
l'accident
le procureur doit qualifier les faits
maintenant et un juge d'instruction
pourrait être nommé dès cet après midi
nancy christophe comptera dans sa toute
dernière interview lady diana avait
dénoncé la férocité d'une presse gay
tancé moindre faux pas la polémique on a
vu s'annonce particulièrement rude sur
les circonstances exactes de ce drame et
sur les responsabilités respectives des
paparazzi à moto et du chauffeur de la
mercedes tout de suite l'analyse de
benoît duquesne en direct
c'est vrai qu'il faut d'abord être très
très prudent et attendre bien sûr les
résultats cette enquête avant de se
prononcer sur une application directe
des paparazzi dans cet accident puisque
les photographes vous le savez s'en
défendent en disant qu'il ne faisait que
suivre quelqu'un qui plus que personne
au monde avait l'habitude de ce genre
d'activité puisque c'était la femme la
plus photographiée du monde mais bien
sûr cette affaire va reposer la question
des délicats rapports entre les stars et
la presse des rapports qui sont bien sûr
inévitable il n'y a pas de starisation
sans médiatisation des rapports qui sont
parfois ambigu on sait des vedettes qui
monnayait arranger deal et les
indiscrétions pouvaient révéler la
presse à leur égard est en tout cas des
rapports qui sont difficiles à définir
on sait qu'il n'ya pas de stars sans
qu'il y est il n'y a pas de stars sans
qu'il y ait une part de sa vie privée
qu'ils soient révélés avant public
le tout est de savoir quelle est
l'importance de cette part de la vie
privée qui doit être révélé
et c'est là toute la limite et c'est là
que depuis quelques années on assiste à
une sorte de dérive de cette presse à
scandale de cette pré sa pipe comme on
dit qui se montre de plus en plus
agressive au nom du droit d'informer
alors il faut dire que la demande est
forte elle aussi puisque pour ne citer
qu'un chiffre les sept principales
publications hebdomadaires qui sont
spécialisés dans ce genre de d'actualité
sur la place de paris est bien
représente plus de 3 millions d'abonnés
fin de lecteurs de d'acheteurs ce qui
veut dire 20 millions de personnes qui
lisent ces journaux l'as et c'est vrai
que beaucoup de gens ici qui faisait le
procès des paparazzi ce matin
reconnaissait que par ailleurs ils
étaient les premiers à se jeter sur les
kiosques pour voir les photos qui
avaient été prises à l'occasion de ces
courses poursuites merci lionel jospin
qui est à la rochelle pour participer à
l'université d'été du ps est venu tôt ce
matin s'incliner devant la dépouille de
la princesse diana
de retour à la rochelle le premier
ministre a adressé ses condoléances aux
enfants de lady die
et bien ce que j'ai ressenti en
apprenant la mort de lady diana
c'est qu'il était profondément triste
que cette belle jeune femme aimée par
les gens mais dont tous les faits était
scruté les faits et les gestes a terminé
sa vie tragiquement en france à paris
je sais que les français ont toujours
été séduit par son charme par son
naturel par son humanité
j'ai eu envie de faire un geste en
direction aussi de nos amis en grande
bretagne naturellement au nom du
gouvernement j'adresse mes condoléances
à la famille royale aux autorités
britanniques et surtout aux enfants et
aux proches de lady diana
[Musique]